la caf
en pologne le gouvernement annonce qu'il
va fermer les chantiers navals de gdansk
c'est le symbole de la contestation
solidarité s'y opposera à tout prix
unique raelienne et ses trois enfants
tués dans un attentat à jéricho en
territoire coûté une nouvelle flambée de
violence qui va peser sur les élections
en algérie nouvelles mesures
d'apaisement avant les élections dans ce
journal le vote des belges est rien en
france entre le doute l'espoir
bravo blanc un succès pour l'instant les
fonctions était beaucoup plus prudent
mais attention les retours seront plus
difficiles
bonsoir cela s'est passé hier soir en
cisjordanie un territoire occupé par
israël un autocar a été attaqué par des
palestiniens
une israélienne et et ses enfants ont
été tués dans l'attentât
c'est une nouvelle fois l'engrenage de
la violence mais aujourd'hui cela prend
une signification particulière en effet
les israéliens votent demain
et cette violence pourrait peser sur le
scrutin
les quatre victimes de l'attaqué de
jéricho ont été enterrés cet après midi
à jérusalem
notre envoyé spécial martin laroche
joubert il y assister la douleur et la
colère mais une colère comme rentrée
retenu à l'image ce communauté juive
ultra-orthodoxe austère fermé à laquelle
appartenait la jeune femme de 27 ans
brûlée vive hier soir avec ses trois
enfants
ils étaient plusieurs centaines à les
accompagner aujourd'hui des religieux
pour qu'ils les territoires occupés ne
sont pas une préoccupation politique la
mort d'une des leurs le hasard et la
fatalité
le cimetière du mont des oliviers
quadrillé aujourd'hui par l'armée
les femmes traditions religieuses
obligeant cette communauté n'assiste pas
à l'innovation
pas de cris ni de pleurs le silence
encore nous serons seulement qu'elle
s'appelait rachel veille une victime de
plus il a dépassé
demain en effet je vous le disais les
israéliens vont aux urnes ils doivent
élire leurs députés ce qui vont siéger à
la knesset face à face deux grands
partis la droite du likoud et la gauche
travailliste la campagne électorale bien
sûr était dominée par la question
palestinienne et les réactions étaient
vives après l'attentât de jéricho à
jérusalem
charles enderlin jéricho cet après-midi
les bulldozer du travail 2007
palestiniens arrêtés hier soir sur les
lieux de l'attentât
un tabou
l'armée a dynamité leur maison
d'autres demeurent derrière lesquels
cité cachée les assaillants sont rasés
les habitants le temps d'en sortir leur
possession
le couvre feu est maintenu les
perquisitions continue arrestations
interrogatoires des dizaines de
personnes ont été interpellées
le ministre de la défense itzhak rabin
est venu discuter avec ses officiers aux
journalistes il a annoncé qu'il
envisageait de réclamer la peine de mort
pour les auteurs de tels crimes d'adulte
faut dire qu'il n'ya eu qu'une seule
exécution capitale en israël depuis la
création de l'état est le criminel nazi
adolf eichmann la peine de mort pour les
terroristes c'est un des slogans du
likoud qui a manifesté à jérusalem en ce
début de soirée une démonstration de
force de la droite à 12 heures des
élections
l'attentât de jéricho at-il fait
basculer les 30 % d'électeurs indécis
qui n'avait pas encore décidé pour qui
voter il ya seulement 48 heures c'est la
question que se pose ce soir toute la
classe politique israélienne
les travaillistes espère que la réaction
très ferme d'itzhak rabin suffire à
empêcher le réflexe sécuritaire
mais dans l'entourage de shimon peres
règne un certain pessimisme
les travaillistes craignent que ce drame
ne leur fasse perdre deux sièges c'est à
dire tous les avantages que leur
accordaient les sondages
en pologne le gouvernement attaque
solidarité de front les chantiers lénine
de gdansk les fameux chantiers navals
vont fermer à partir du 1er décembre
c'est un symbole car les chantiers
navals avait été le berceau de la
contestation
c'est là aussi que lech walesa est
encore électricien on comprend bien sûr
que solidarité et décidé de s'opposer à
cette fermeture par tous les moyens
jean marc et 12 officiellement c'est
pour des raisons strictement économique
que le gouvernement polonais veut fermer
les chantiers navals de danse c'est vrai
les effectifs des chantiers lénine sont
déjà passés de 17000 à onze mille
ouvriers et produisent déjà trois fois
moins qu il y a dix ans c'est vrai il en
coûte à l'état des milliards de
subventions aux notices l'amener
polonaise voilà en tout cas la thèse du
nouveau premier ministre polonais meech
et staff rakowski un homme qui se veut
réformiste est modéré et qui a promis de
restructurer l'économie polonaise
en misant sur l'ouverture politique mais
en disant non au pluralisme syndical
donc à solidarité d'où la colère du chef
du syndicat interdit l'air va les a
toujours électriciens etc dans ce qu'il
qualifie la décision du pouvoir polonais
de provocation pure et simple les
entreprises nationales malades en effet
ne manquent pas en pologne
et si aujourd'hui le régime du général
jaruzelski prévoit d'abord de recycler
les bons ouvriers de danse c'est à
l'évidence pour se débarrasser des
autres membres du syndicat clandestins
18 ans après les sanglantes
manifestations de septembre 70 les
chantiers qui ont vu la naissance puis
l'étouffement de solidarité reste le
quartier général où s'organise bien des
mouvements de grève en pologne depuis
celle du mois d'août
le gouvernement polonais semblait avoir
opté pour la négociation
il paraît ce soir avoir de nouveau
décidé la confrontation
donc les chantiers navals de gdansk eux
vont fermer dès le 1er décembre mais
georges bortoli c'est vrai que tous les
chantiers navals européens ont des
difficultés alors peut-être que les
chantiers de danse ont de réelles
difficultés aussi certain donc après
text économique qui est tout à fait bon
seulement c'est vrai aussi qu'en paul
ahyi vous avez des dizaines
d'entreprises qui sont tout aussi
déficitaires alors on choisissant de
fermes et de liquides et de démanteler
celles là et pas une autre
visiblement le pouvoir cherche à
humilier solidarité parce que dans ce
cas le chantier lénine c'est le lieu de
naissance de solidarité et c'est
toujours resté leurs places fortes
pourquoi le pouvoir fait ça maintenant
et bien parce qu'il ya un nouveau
ministre depuis trois semaines qui
s'appelle monsieur rakowski qui est un
homme intelligent habile et qui est un
adversaire tout à fait déterminé
solidarité alors on s'attendait à ce
qu'il prenne offensive c'est fait que
peut-il se passer maintenant pouvoir
espère que ce qui va se passer c'est que
ça va réussir parce que les ouvriers du
port sont fatigués d'autres parce qu'il
fait froid en pologne il faisait moins
10 hier alors supposer une tentative
d'occupation des chantiers comme
solidarité sait très bien le faire il
suffirait de couper l'électricité et le
froid deviendrait
nabeul mais dites-moi lech walesa il
était électricien au chantier naval de
danse donc il va se retrouver au chômage
technique
l'électricien à lézat va se retrouver au
chômage probablement est le leader et ça
va se trouver en difficulté politique en
tout cas c'est ce qu'espère le fouloir
polonais qui il faut le dire
aj un petit peu à contre courant des
intentions généreuses que monsieur
gorbatchev proclame à moscou merci
georges en algérie
et là aussi chez les élections
approchent c'est jeudi prochain le 3 le
président chadli a annoncé aujourd'hui
deux mesures d'apaisement
d'une part la mise en liberté provisoire
de tous ceux qui ont été arrêtées
pendant les émeutes et puis d'autre part
les mesures d'assistance aux familles
des victimes des émeutes
je dis donc les algériens vont voter
mais tout de suite sur ces mesures
d'apaisement je vous propose d'écouter à
alger ce que nous en dit est tout à leur
bruno le dreff bruno une nouvelle fois
le président chadli a donc pris tout le
monde de vitesse on attendait pour
demain 1er novembre des mesures d'
amnistie elles sont annoncées dès
aujourd'hui et d'après les
renseignements que j'ai pu recueillir ce
soir à alger
toutes les personnes qui se trouvaient
incarcérés à la suite des émeutes du
début du mois sont désormais en liberté
ce qui ne veut pas dire pour autant
qu'elle soit graciée je trouve
simplement en liberté provisoire et
devront répondre devant les tribunaux
des charges qui pèsent contre elle à
savoir pour la plupart des cas de
pillage et de vandalisme le communiqué
qui annonce ces mesures fait également
savoir que le président chadli tout en
déplorant les morts occasionné par les
émeutes a demandé je cite que soient
mises en place des mesures d'assistance
concrètes appropriée aux victimes et à
leurs familles quatre jours avant
l'important référendum qui touchent des
mesures constitutionnelles
il semble donc bien que le président
chadli feuilletait nouveau faire preuve
de sa volonté d'ouverture
voilà alors il ya le vote à propos du
référendum toujours il ya le vote de
ceux qui sont sur place en algérie et
puis il ya aussi ceux qui sont à
l'étranger par exemple en france ils
sont huit cent mille chez nous et leur
choix même s'ils ne votent pas tous
peizerat incontestablement cette
communauté d'algériens en france vous
allez le voir elle est divisée
il y a ceux qui espèrent mais il ya ceux
qui doutent pascal deschamps didier da
en reportage
blanc pour le oui jaune pour le non les
bulletins sont arrivés d'alger il ya
quinze jours pour ces centaines de
milliers d'algériens immigrés souvent
traumatisés par les derniers événements
bien décidé à faire entendre leur voix
vous sentez concerné par ce référendum
doit bien sûr ce pour cela que ça va
avoir des changes quand même un algérie
ils vont changer un petit peu de
politiques en valent plus puissants on
va peut être traités comme des bêtes on
est des humains de la liberté des jeunes
pour eux de son bureau de vote ont été
ouverts dans toute la france consulat ou
comme ici bureau de l'amicale des
algériens en europe
souvent accusée d'être une émanation du
fln et de faire pression sur la
communauté algérienne
une policière qui est la peau suivants
algérie et connaître leurs agissements
et dénonce éventuellement on a vu on a
vu des algériens je vais retirer leurs
passeports aux balcons suis là parce
qu'un militant responsables d'amicales
les avaient dénoncés comme étant
opposants des accusations que l'amicale
rejette formellement
même si elle appelle à voter oui au
référendum elle dit ce qu'on tentait
d'expliquer le projet de réforme comme
ici dans un foyer de la région
parisienne mais on a vu que la nouvelle
constitution
le premier ministre a le droit d'exercer
certains pouvoirs
par exemple si lui qui disait les
ministres ont bac il présente la liste
au président de la république qui va les
nommer quelqu'un à bord vous venez chez
nous pour parler de cette élection c'est
bien mais fait nous bien comprendre à
quoi elle sert dans la république
populaire algérienne la révolution doit
se faire pour le peuple et par le peuple
bon alors ce référendum on ne comprend
pas à quoi il sert on confond ne disent
ils pas messieurs la mie câline sue
ellen brosseau
vous savez tout le monde ce qui se passe
dans notre pays les tissus
via nos collègues qui sauf il ya ne pas
petit chouchou vous et intellectuel que
vous êtes intelligent vous vous deviez
nous exprimer ce qu'il faut faire
le faire comprendre parce que la nama
qui s'acquittent h quelque chose qu'il y
a des corrompus qu'il ya du trafic
nous l'avons toujours dit et alors happy
à qui allons nous le cacher non
maintenant s'il s'agit de détruire
algérie tout simplement parce qu'on a
des problèmes
je crois qu'on est capable de laver
notre linge sale en famille chez les
karoubi c'est décidé on ne votera pas ni
la mère ancienne militante du fln ni les
enfants ne croit plus au changement pour
moi j'appellerai ce référendum le
référent temps de la honte
à partir du moment où le sang de
milliers d'innocents et écoulée je ne
crois pas leur parole je ne crois pas
leur parle
ainsi va la communauté algérienne en
france tiraillé entre lé doute et
l'espoir
toxicomanie et sida deux termes qui
malheureusement doivent être associés
car il est clair maintenant que la
toxicomanie est le principal facteur de
transmission du sida dans une interview
à libération ce matin le ministre de la
santé claude evin précise la politique
du gouvernement en cette matière sur
deux points notamment oui à la vente
libre des seringues institué par le
précédent ministre est mise en place de
centres spéciaux pour accueillir des
femmes séropositives et toxicomane qui
viennent d'accoucher
alors comment cela peut-il se passer
dans la pratique en quête de daniel
duigou à l'association trait d'union une
association qui prend en charge les
toxicomanes
lorsqu'ils sortent de prison daniel 30
ans a renoncé à avoir un enfant parce
qu'elle se sait séropositif depuis trois
mois elle a décroché après 10 ans
d'héroïne et elle a retrouvé un travail
aujourd'hui
elle approuve la création de centres
médicaux pour les mères et les enfants
atteints de sida de préférence à
d'autres types de centres je pense aussi
que c'est une bonne idée plutôt que
plutôt qu'elles se baladent je vais dire
dans la nature parce que je pense qu'il
faut qu'elle soit suivie ou et mais je
parle pas des centres genre sida thorium
qu'on m'en a parlé patriarche surtout
pas ça pour quoi parce que je pense
qu'il est inutile de se mettre ensemble
les gens qui soient séropositifs ou au
candidat je veux dire c'est des gens
comme tout le monde qu'on besoin de
d'amour d'affection et qui peuvent très
bien mener une vie normale quoi vous
admettez qu'il faut quand même les
suivre du médical oui mais ça c'est eux
qui font les démarches et qui se font
suivre par par un professeur points
reste qu'au trait d'union l'on a prise
en charge cette année plus de 500
nouveaux jeunes
on pense que les mesures ne sont pas
suffisantes je crois que le sida pris la
haute main si vous voulez c'est
tellement dramatique km main sur la
lutte contre la drogue mais moi en tant
que spécialiste toxicomanie je continue
à penser que vénaux
est on encore l'âge de pierre la matière
de l'ipo 3 trucks matière de prévention
je crois que tout reste à faire au
niveau de la prévention
je crois qu'il faut faire quelque chose
pour que lorsque la demande de drogue
arrive lorsque mettons à l'enfant à 14
15 16 ans et que quelqu'un un jour je
suis ici tu proposes la drogue qui soit
capable de dire non au trait d'union
environ 70% des jeunes tous ancien
toxico sont séropositifs l'intolérance
en justice tu ce week-end neuf personnes
ont été inculpées dont trois incarcérées
ce sont celles qui ont commis des
attentats contre les cinémas qui
projetait la dernière tentation du
christ le film de scorsese
pour l'instant il est bien difficile de
faire le lien exact entre ces fanatiques
et les dirigeants des mouvements
intégristes
ces derniers se défendent ce sont
pourtant eux qui ont tant poussé à
l'intolérance agnès poirier c'est bien
du centre charlier et de chrétienté
solidarité que tout a commencé
tous sauf l'attentât précisent les
responsables mais les manifestations les
graffitis les jets de lacrymogène tout
était consigné dans une note envoyée aux
sympathisants
pourtant bernard antony alias romain
mary responsable de ces deux
associations traditionalistes et député
du front national au parlement européen
s'est défendu aujourd'hui d'en être
l'auteur
le coupable furent motive c'est michel
valadier permanent de l'association il a
quitté le 8 octobre dernier pour suivre
monseigneur lefebvre mecili valadier
organisée très bien la manifestation de
la place de l'opéra
mady jordanie de manifestations par
ailleurs et donc je ne suis pas occupée
des détails encore une fois c'est nantes
qui l'a envoyé et dont on fait tout un
plat mais c'est quelque chose de
parfaitement dérisoire enfin est
d'ailleurs j'observe la police
parfaitement observé ce dérisoire et que
le juge d'instruction qu'un recours
remis licha lui valent à dire liberté
on a tout de même vu d'autres avec huit
autres personnes michel valadier est
aujourd'hui inculpé dans la sphère de
l'attentât contre le cinéma saint michel
côté agitation sociale c'est plus calme
pour deux raisons d'abord à cause bien
sûr du grand week-end mais aussi parce
que les conflits les plus graves ont
trouvé semble-t-il une solution reste
des points noirs les ptt dans certaines
villes
il par exemple ou encore les transports
en commun c'est le cas à lyon et à
nantes tout de suite le point nicolas
jacobs 21e journée de grève au centre de
tri de lille 2 n 3 millions d'objets en
souffrance est toujours l'impasse seuls
cinq camions chargés de courrier ont pu
quitter le centre avant que les piquets
de grève ne reprennent position les
dernières offres de la direction était
jugé insuffisantes les grévistes
demandent l'embauché de personnel
supplémentaire et l'attribution d'une
prime de fin d'année de 1050 francs
en région parisienne les chauffeurs de
quatre garages ptt ont également
reconduit leur mouvement de grève
le drapeau blanc n'a pas désarmé les
traminots lyonnais les transports en
commun de lyon tout comme ceux de
saint-etienne et nantes sont totalement
paralysés
la grève a été reconduite il faudra
attendre mercredi pour que les
négociations reprennent
d'autres temps forts de l'actualité
internationale ce lundi terry anderson
l'un des otages américains au liban les
négociations de paix entre l'iran et
l'irak qui reprennent et la chute
interminable de la maison marcos voyons
tout cela en images avec emmanuel vanier
ronald reagan a totalement échoué sur la
question des otages américains
c'est terry anderson qui s'exprime dans
une cassette vidéo remise à une agence
de presse par ses ravisseurs du jihad
islamique
après plus de trois ans et demi de
détention terry anderson est le doyen
des otages occidentaux liban il affirme
je cite la sphère des otages aurait pu
être réglé depuis longtemps par ronald
reagan
il regrette que cette question était
très peu évoquée lors de la campagne
présidentielle américaine
ils appellent enfin le prochain
président des états unis à négocier la
libération des otages américains du
liban
échange de prisonniers hier entre l'iran
et l'irak mais ils sont seulement 25 de
chaque camp selon la croix rouge
internationale il y aurait plus de 70
mille prisonniers de guerre dans les
deux pays
leur libération dépend de la rapidité
avec laquelle évolueront les
négociations de genève qui ont repris
aujourd'hui entre les ministres des
affaires étrangères des deux pays
selon perez de cuellar secrétaire
général de l'onu le cessez-le-feu
restera très fragile tant que l'iran
l'irak ne sont pas parvenus à un accord
sur le retrait des troupes sur les
frontières internationalement reconnues
imelda marcos devant la justice
américaine
ferdinand marcos l'ex dictateur
philippin n'a pu faire le voyage entre
hawaï et new york pour raisons de santé
le juge new yorkais a exigé la présence
de sa femme imelda tous deux sont en
effet accusés de détournement de fonds
600 millions de francs pour acheter
immeubles et oeuvres d'art à new york un
record qui ne fait vraiment pas rire 262
km heure sur une autoroute c'était tout
à l'heure entre nancy et dijon un
automobiliste suisse au volant d'une
porsche a été contrôlé à cette vitesse
incroyable et stupide
c'est le mauvais exemple du week-end
l'exemple à ne pas suivre les français
dans l'ensemble on était beaucoup plus
raisonnable que lui les chiffres de
l'opération drapeau blanc montre que les
français veulent faire quelque chose
pour éviter l'hécatombe sur les routes
gérard holtz les chiffres que vous avez
ce soir témoigne de cela oui
les chiffres très encourageants hervé
claude même si cet après midi il y a eu
le même nombre d'accidents 1983 le
fameux week-end thèse qu'en 1988 on va
les regarder tout de suite sur ce
tableau la 118 accident en 1983 et en
mais regardez la différence il y avait
eu 12 tués en 83 il y en a seulement 4,7
après midi alors ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les accidents était
moins grave est que la vitesse a été
beaucoup plus respectés maintenant le
cumul depuis trois jours de cette
opération drapeau blanc on voit les
chiffres là beaucoup moins d'accidents
1592 seulement est beaucoup moins de
tuer aussi 93 tués au lieu de 140 3
c'est à dire que sur le bilan de
l'opération drapeau blanc pour l'instant
on va le voir s'afficher ici nous étions
1,42 vie sauve et maintenant nous en
sommes à 50/50 vies sauvées mais le
début de l'opération drapeau blanc we
are le week-end n'est pas terminé et ça
va peut-être être le plus dur les
recueillir normalement il faut faire
très attention dans la nuit qui vient
pourquoi parce qu'il va y avoir des
dîner arrosé il va y avoir des fêtes
il va y avoir des gens qui vont sortir
ce soir qui vont aller en boîte de nuit
on va boire et la nuit qui vient est
l'une des nuits les plus dangereuses
parce que demain il ya la grasse matinée
c'est encore un jour de congé d'eux
il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont sortir
ce soir alors c'est la nuit qui vient
qui va tout déterminé mais c'est quand
même très encourageant parce que vos
vies sauvées vendredi 30 samedi 40 vies
sauvées dimanche aujourd'hui on en est à
50 le drapeau blanc et ce soir gérard on
vous retrouve tout de suite après dans
l'émission de jean marie cavada de
norbert ben ali et juste après le
journal aussi avec un document car cet
après-midi un terrible accident à
toulouse et nous nous étions sur les
lieux avec claude sérillon se retrouve
tout à l'heure merci gérard autre prise
de conscience l'environnement jusqu'à
présent les français n'y ont jamais été
très sensible et pourtant la pollution
industrielle s'attaque à tous la nature
comme les hommes voyez les arbres morts
dans les forêts des vosges par exemple
voyez aussi les maladies qu'entraînent
les déchets toxiques et bien douze pays
d'europe viennent de prendre un
engagement très important ils vont
réduire d'un tiers les émissions
d'oxydés d'azoté dans leur pays dans les
dix prochaines années
explication patrice pelé tous les ans en
france 1 million 600 mille tonnes
d'oxydé d'azoté sont rejetées dans
l'atmosphère
le résultat le voilà la pierre de nos
cathédrales ronger les métaux attaqué
dans le massif des vosges des centaines
d'hectares de sapins sont comme brûler
mail oxydes d'azoté a aussi une autre
cible le poumon des hommes ce matin la
france et 12 pays d'europe se sont
engagés à réduire ensemble et en disant
de 30%
cette pollution chimique par l'oxydé
d'azoté les mesures les nouvelles
installations industrielles comme les
grosses chaudières de groupes
d'immeubles par exemple ou les centrales
thermiques devront être munis de
dispositifs d'épuration tout ce qui
roule tout ce qui pollue voitures
camions devront être équipés le plus
vite possible de
analytique comme le prévoit l'accord de
luxembourg passé en juin 80 ça pour la
france comme pour les 12 pays d'europe
cet engagement est important c'est la
volonté affichée des gouvernements de
voir plus propre le ciel des grandes
villes et des campagnes
c'est aussi le moyen de faire payer les
pollueurs grâce à une réglementation
stricte et précise
beaucoup moins nocif est beaucoup plus
beau le peintre mathieu qui expose à
paris c'est un événement car cela fait
des années que ça n'était pas arrivé
mathieu lhomme d'un style qui la gardait
tout au long de sa carrière
mathieu qui revient très fortement à la
mode avec le retour des sixties
mathieu à qui nous devons nous en tête
de l'un de nos premiers cycles pierre
champetier georges mathieu un homme de
guerre
autrefois et célébrer les grandes
batailles de l'histoire
aujourd'hui les luttes des minorités
opprimées pour lui l'acte de peindre
fera toujours un combat s'est improvisé
h aux commandes la vitesse d'exécution
mais commande aussi des moments de
concentration et danses des cas limites
d'extase c'est la concentration qui qui
remplace tout ce que l'on croyait venir
autrefois des muses
n'est ce pas ce qu'on appelle
inspiration unique en même temps pour
votre épargne
tel un guerrier du moyen-âge partant à
l'assaut d'une muraille georges mathieu
va s'attaquer maintenant à la décoration
d'un barrage de 120 mètres de long
demain il ya un tiercé quarté + cette
hauteur
il n'y a que douze partants alors voici
les pronostics de pierrette brès pour ce
tiercé quarté + le 3 le cincle de l'as
leucate le dise le 6 et le 7 voient la
fin de cette édition
prochain rendez vous ce sera henri
sannier vers 23h excellente soirée sur
antenne 2 à demain vingtaine
oh